[Music]
we have team coverage this afternoon as
we continue to follow the breaking news
here at home las vegas metro police
updating us on the investigation into
the murder of review journal reporter
jeff gearman now we're getting a first
look at the mug shot of robert tellis a
county official who was arrested
yesterday for the murder of german 8
news now investigator david charge joins
us live at metro headquarters with what
he's now learned david
well heather as the 8 news now
investigators first reported last night
dna from items found in robert telles's
west valley home connected him to the
murder of jeff german and sheriff joe
lombardo and the detectives working this
case gave us an update here at metro
headquarters just about two hours ago
you saw it right here on eight news now
those detectives saying that they found
a bloody shoe inside telus home they
also say they found a hat matching the
one that you saw in that surveillance
video that detectives have released had
released of a suspect just days ago we
now know that that person in that video
was telus walking away from german's
home moments before
his stabbing death now today sources
telling the investigators telus stabbed
german seven times as you saw in our
reporting yesterday police released
telus after questioning him only to then
arrest him just a couple hours later and
we had that barricade we aired live
so i asked police why there was a delay
we wanted to provide a medical attention
which we were successful in doing so and
then we also wanted to make sure that we
were consulting with our district
attorney's office and ensuring a solid
case to keep building evidence and
that's what we did successfully thank
you
sources telling the investigators that
telus harmed himself in his home before
his arrest police also telling us the
suv you saw in those photos and then the
one that they found in telus's driveway
and towed away is registered in telus's
wife's name they tell us telus became a
suspect early on due to those public
comments he had made about german in his
reporting back out here live sheriff joe
lombardo making a rare public appearance
because of this high profile case they
put so many resources in solving this in
solving this homicide quickly we will
tell you what the sheriff said and also
bring you some new details coming up
this afternoon live at four o'clock for
now i'm david charns live outside metro
my colleague victoria saha is live
outside the regional justice center
where robert telus is expected to be in
court at 1 30 this afternoon victoria
what are you learning
hey there david thank you yep robert
telus will be facing the judge for the
first time since being charged with the
murder of jeff german and it was an
intense situation that led up to his
arrest starting from yesterday morning
up until late last night as police tried
to take custody and charge telus
ultimately it was dna evidence that led
police to their suspect
ever since jeff gearman was found
stabbed to death outside his home
saturday morning police have been urging
for the public's help to find his killer
after releasing new video of the suspect
and a potential car earlier in the week
by wednesday telus was the prime suspect
wednesday morning police issued a search
warrant at telus house questioning him
at metro and they confiscated potential
evidence including his car and clothing
hours later telus returned home in a
white jumpsuit and refused to comment
then as police were trying to contact
him there was no answer at the door
sources tell our 8 news now
investigators telus was taken into
custody after he was taken to the
hospital with non-life-threatening
self-inflicted wounds our 8 news now
cameras were there as he was wheeled in
now for the first time we are hearing
from
gearman's family they sent in a
statement to eight news now saying in
part we're shocked we're saddened and
angry about his death jeff was committed
to seeking justice for others and would
appreciate the hard work by local police
again robert tellis will be in court in
just over an hour he's facing an open
murder charge i'm going to go ahead and
send it over to my colleague candace is
outside the public administrator's
office candace has there been any new
developments
very good after folks well the
building where robert tell us work is
still closed and i've spoken to some of
the people who are running for his
position now and they tell me that this
all comes as a shock of course the
public administration building was
searched by police wednesday morning
employees were told to go home wednesday
afternoon and it's been closed ever
since i reached out to the city official
who beat tell us in the primaries for
the position read read her husband told
me her phone was confiscated during the
search reads on the november ballot with
tablet al debac and patsy brown for tell
us his position as public administrator
brown's campaign team told me this
incident has everyone including brown on
alert
the concern of personal safety
and i know that's something that a lot
of the employees of the public
administrator's office even the
candidates who are also
seeking office for public administrator
that's something that is going to
resonate and be at the forefront of
their mind
brown had a bit of controversy herself
she was recently arrested for a dui her
campaign team says she's been warning
her father and that she was set to meet
with german next week i reached out to
tabitha and didn't get a response but
the county sent this statement saying
quote the death of jeff german was both
shocking and tragic and we joined with
our community and being stunned at how
this situation has continued to evolve
over the last few days the public
administrator is an elected position and
the county is reviewing its options
under the law regarding robert telus's
current status as the public
administrator the safety of our county
employees and the public is our top
priority and the county has suspended mr
telus access to county offices or
property they say it is undetermined at
this time when this building will be
open of course we will keep you up to
date with stick with us right here for
the latest heather
all right candace thank you so much for
that report now gearman as we've
reported was a journalist here in las
vegas for nearly four decades on the las
vegas review journal executive editor
released a statement on the arrest and
here's what it reads in part
the arrest of robert tellis is at once
an enormous relief and an outrage for
the review journal newsroom we're
relieved that telus is in custody and
outraged that a colleague appears to
have been killed for reporting on an
elected official